all right Adrian Adrian Oh where'd you
grow up where you from originally I was
putting you sell a group in city of
Commerce went to Bell Gardens high got
into some trouble and my scenario
finished off in Montebello got a full
ride to Cal State LA I was a pole
vaulter and gah I just drugs alcohol
yeah what a jury when you first good sir
wait what age were you when you first
got off the drugs
when I first got when I first drank I
was nine years old and when I first
started smoking pot I was about 15 and
then after that it scared me tell me
about your family you grew up with two
parents no um my mom I grew up with my
mom very strong woman middle I was the
middle child she my oldest brother was
the golden boy and my younger son was up
to six so I bore the brunt of everything
her mom did to her and she was no colic
as well and she would she would beat me
and she would she'd sexually abused me
Hank
wouldn't she do that
I didn't stop sleeping in the same bed
with her till I was 12 and I am and
that's when I went to go stay with my
brother in Spain I'm using the air force
and then his his wife seduced me
that did that happen it's been pretty
much no stability in my entire life it's
just been paying out I was a cutter I
just stopped cutting last year right now
that was another way to deal with with
everything and yeah just
you know I've been married four times
called visa women I have two boys my
other sons 29 and my intersects 26 now
that she sends an animator he works with
Studios Burbank he does his runs ahead
and my younger son is a chef the life of
me I can't remember the name of the
restaurant it's here in downtown LA your
kids are great yes I was completely
transparent with them from the get-go
and I pretty much said if my older son i
groomed him to be an animator I mean I
always wanted to be one but I couldn't
get it together and it had no discipline
so that's all he ever wanted to do and
when he started to you know I would say
anything for when he started to test
drugs or experiment
I told me you have to make a choice
either you're gonna give your life over
the drugs and you know just be like your
old man or or be an animator you kid
there's no there's no mixing that you
and my younger son is well he's he's
also a writer he um he would take his
skateboard down a Venice Beach and said
his old typewriter and self poems or
sonnets or LAN do this for two dollars a
pop his fiancee met him there took a
picture of him put it on the Internet
and he went viral and he still gets
commissions from loud like Spain and
France for just poems he's a he's
published to do poetry books already
sell finance and
it's been it's been tough because they
went from God being this hero to then
seem sad truth of the alcoholic drug
addict and now it's kind of a they don't
you know I'm sometimes treated with the
UH I get like a stray dog
you know just say you know I've been
trying to I actually started a couple a
month ago a little bit over a month ago
that's off the wagon and I was
bartending and it was really just you
know and they they kind of hinted to me
that hey you know it's no drinking on
the job yesterday when I went into work
before I started to be sat me down and
they said you know you're a great guy
and everything but you have a drinking
problem and I was like well I know that
you know and then my girl I just bailed
and I've been down here since yesterday
that's get rough yeah yeah so it's
alcohol and crack that are your well
alcohol triggers everything you know
it's it's it's the it's the thing that I
can go get at the store that's readily
available everywhere everywhere and as
soon as I get enough in me before you
know it I'm down it on the Gladys you
know oh yeah and you know
hey it it doesn't I want to see it
doesn't work for me anymore because it
never worked for me but it was always
something that I could count on you know
I don't really have any friends or the
closest thing to a family that I've had
is my gallery with two kids and I you
know it's almost like I don't I I can't
accept the good you know
and I've worked on it I mean I've seen a
lot of therapists his stuff but it just
doesn't seem real you know now a student
really get there for a couple weeks and
you know I was feeling I was looking
really bad I mean I had I had been on on
a bender for a couple of months where I
was waking up and drinking and I was
going through to 750 s of Smirnoff a day
and then that but drinking at work you
know I guess it showed more than I
thought it did but it was until recently
that they brought to my attention that
what that they that they brought to my
attention they brought to my attention
two weeks ago on a Sunday and they're
like well you know they pretty much said
we're gonna let this one slide and you
know and even with that I
I still drank subject work you know my
girl didn't I was drinking you know
smoking weed and drinking vodka on the
way to work and showing up to work and
doing my job and drinking at work and
you know stopping the drink well with
enough time so that when I did get home
I didn't smell and yeah this is I'd like
to say it's a new low but it's not you
know it's the the only people that have
ever really been affected by my drinking
has been my girl and and my boys and
that's it everybody else pretty much you
know it wasn't important enough to even
say anything about it except when I
would get sloppy not show and don't get
yelled at but like you know I had a I I
got hired as as the house band at a
coffee shop in Sherman Oaks right down
the street from Casa Vega and today was
gonna be my first show and and I'm here
and I I don't know I don't know what's
gonna happen next
you know I I'd saved 1,200 bucks to get
me into an apartment
and then brought it and left it here I'm
pretty much over the course yeah what do
you think I mean is there a history of
addiction in your family alcoholism
yeah alcoholism I'm not sure if there
was other stuff but my uncle died of
cirrhosis drank to the deed died I know
he did coke to my mom drank my mom drank
well until well until I was like halfway
through high school and then she just
stopped you know but
yes far as alcoholism news there's
there's addiction in my family my
grandmother smoked her had another
smoked two packs of 100 Mors menthols
every day drank her six-pack of coke
Cola every day she'd lived to be 98 and
she was bit by a cat when the infection
killed her yeah but she was you know
she's she's she lived in Sinaloa Posada
which is very you know the only paid pay
prostitute she would be like in the
middle of town and everything else is
just sort of a cross street from the
graveyard that had no no wall around it
so that's it was just very so she'd be
out there every day you know you know
overseeing eggs killing chickens and and
you know doing farm work and she's you
know but uh I I've been I've been able
to be a functional addict pretty much my
whole life and I used to think that was
a really cool thing and now it's it's
terrifying
because obviously I'm not a functional
addict because I'm here now I guess
after certain amount of time I'm almost
50 you know and I haven't done anything
you know I've written a lot and you know
I've got 20 songs in there they're great
songs home about drugs and alcohol and
but as cautionary tales though you know
I never glorified it I mostly drank by
myself into drugs by myself when I was
when I was in a band in the 90s
there was that whole party scene you
know and the guitar player his wife had
divorced him left in the million dollar
home in Chino Hills and it was a great
time but even then I mean I would get
home from the show and you know ever be
there all the chicks you know I was a
singer so all the chicks want to get at
me I go upstairs and do my drugs and
lock the door and watch pornography and
write and draw and you know accused of
being yeah male you know because I
didn't I don't know sex to me is kind of
a it's a strange thing
you know I up until now with you know
and I I was a male escort in my twins
and that was pretty much the same you
know and it was when I was with the boys
mom and she was all for it cuz it saved
me a lot of money and but there's always
been this thing about sex with me that
that's not that it's ugly but it's it's
not I don't have you I enjoy sex and
then I you know I when I was a kid I was
introduced to pornography very early on
and that was where I would find the
closeness you know watching people
having sex
that's why I'd sign in tennis and I
think I carried that out
until just recently with you know the
girl at him she's my best friend I don't
even want to call her my girlfriend I've
been able to really let go so that you
know but it's still you think those
experiences you had with definitely
damaged me yeah yeah yeah because my dad
it's funny my mom she is awkward and it
out which is like I don't know if you
ever heard of like Santeria and it comes
from my grandfather's side they they
were all they all dabbled in witchcraft
adalah snap but she was she's a healer
and still is and my dad I met him when I
was 21 and he's a pastor and didn't like
me one bit cuz he said I was too
opinionated
and I asked him any questions actually
called me big now he died last year and
you know I met my whole other side of
the family there you know my half
brothers and sisters and stuff and
they're like oh you know I'm like I
don't I don't feel anything and I didn't
feel anything for him I mean I met him I
met him like a handful of times from 21
till last year and you know I mean you
know they're like oh you got to come
with a party we're gonna celebrate his
life I'm like what am I gonna say I
don't have any cool stories about him
not only we have much to say you know so
I made my peace you know say I I don't
wish him I never wished him I never
wished Mineola I was very angry though
for a long time as well as with my mom
but then I learned to release that I
buried them because it turns out I was
doing their job for them even after they
were you know we're around anymore I was
still abusing myself for them and yeah
so I mean I've made some progress in my
life I've very a very self observant and
you know I don't lie you know I every
therapist everyone - they're like well
you know it would have taken us like
three months to get to what we got to in
this first session I'm like why didn't
you want to get better so the quicker I
tell you everything
the quicker we can get down to business
but eventually it would be a thing where
they would kind of Peter out because I I
just the answers they were getting they
weren't enough although I did learn that
that I wasn't possessed by demons that I
just had a chemical imbalance because
growing up my mom would tell me cuz I
had
and bipolar and I have even been
diagnosed borderline Priscilla and I
watch ISM but uh gotta tell you man I
was relief to find out that but there
was just something here that I could
figure out and fix and that it wasn't
something you know another world
scary waiting for you dead but uh yeah
I'm very spiritual you know I'm very not
very
I've been referred to in my life has a
sweet man you know very kind and very
generous and I give everything that I
wasn't given growing up word that I
didn't get in any part of my life so as
matter of fact my children then I never
yelled at them and they never knew you a
heavy hand for me ever even when they
were tiny you know I was like no way the
chain stops here because my mom was
abused my mom was abused and so on and
so forth so that's one thing that can
say that I've done in his life is that
they they were raised with that and with
logic and I'm gonna cue no even when
they were tiny and there was no verbal
communication you know there was just
that if I wasn't freaking out there were
there was some you know it you know went
to design school they taught us there
that language is third on the list of
communication you know it's images and
then music and then and then language
because you can go anywhere in the world
and know which bathrooms men's which
ones women
and you know everybody loves great music
even if they don't understand words yeah
so I've always kind of worked from from
that place but right now I really wish I
had the balls take that back I I really
wish that I had a suicidal personality
so I could just be done but
I I've always had a strong relationship
with God and I I can't be the one to go
how I'm done I don't know what I meant
for what I'm still here I mean I should
be dead thousands times over and I'm not
and even though I would want him to shut
it off in others as I get older it gets
a little stronger but I I can't I can't
I know I could excite any you know it's
a I couldn't I haven't done you know I
like that's not much to be left on an
epitaph you know I want I want there to
be more
yeah
we had your thank you so much for
sharing your story
cool I think the fact you raised your
kids and they're walking straight back
is a great accomplishment yeah it is but
I want something for me too
whereas I never thought that I deserved
it none of them to like few years ago so
you know actually I think believing you
deserve it is a really key part of the
whole yes yes it's the most important
part of it my girl is the one that
started introducing me to that kind of
thought I talked to a thousand people
now and what I see when I hear over and
over and over and over is I don't
deserve it I don't deserve it I belong
here I'm worthless just to change that
way of thinking which is not easy you
know I think is the key yeah but and
that that's that's all that's all I knew
forever until about you know four years
ago when I started down that path
you know and that's what I mean I think
that's the key yeah yeah yeah thank you
very much